we got the sponsorship late last night I
am a big fan of the the natural world
Ben knows this I love I love the nature
I love to swim
I'll of pools but even more importantly
I love lakes and I love oceans these are
things that I am invested in and I mean
I've never been a hysterical warming on
either side
climate change is probably real uh you
know and and and maybe we could do
something positive about it I don't know
but I love swimming I grew up around the
ocean and I grew up swimming as a kid
with my mother these are the things
always remember about my childhood the
smell of salt water and the sand under
your feet running around I mean this is
so when when we destroy the oceans we're
destroying not only are our habitats or
destroying all these great experiences
so we're very happy to kind of we're
this new project that we're backing
right now and we're trying to involve a
lot of our people in it as well and just
a few minutes of it to just kind of tell
you what it what it's about
the weather is very very important to us
it actually affects every single aspect
of our lives
she's right before I came to Iceland I
checked the weather I'm super happy that
I did my umbrella was handy last night
I'm sure it was for many of you
farmers are it's essential for farming
when to plant the crops when to take and
when to harvest the crops so I'm
delighted today for the first time to be
able to have the Weather Channel have a
look at what's happening for the first
time in history actually in the high
seas thank you so much Gillian and we've
got wonderful new technology here at the
Weather Channel and we are able to
deliver a point forecast for the Arctic
high season we'll take one location that
is north of the northernmost part of
Canada near the Mian Islands and as you
might expect it's going to be very
chilly indeed here temperatures will for
the most part only get up into the
negative 20s Celsius through the entire
week so you want to take an extra pair
of knickers should you be here anytime
soon and we'll take you to another spot
on the other side of the Arctic Ocean
and that is north of Russia northeast of
the Anzu Islands and
it's going to be quite cold temperatures
in the negative numbers all across the
board right through the end of the week
getting a little bit warmer going into
Thursday Friday and Saturday now back to
you in Iceland thank you that's clever
because what she did I don't know who
this woman is what she's doing is she's
trying to get people into supporting the
oceans but she's using things they know
like The Weather Channel
I I like this a lot I don't know she is
but she's got a bright future today
because that is a first for the Arctic
it is a first for the high seas and it's
a first for the Weather Channel so
what's this focus on the weather it's
really exciting of course that now for
the first time in history we have the
weather for the high seas in the Arctic
that's about 1% of the high seas in
total but what that really means is that
almost half the planet we have no
weather for think about that for a
second five crazy most half the fact
that we don't have full and full data
for the weather offerings real people
and our friends from the fisheries data
is especially this year isn't it and a
turkey so it's exciting that is I just
want to talk of a little bit about
exploration so let's end I like going on
budget is about 250 times more than my
life what does your budget bringing it
is some of the reasons for the holes in
our ocean exploration to put this into
perspective on the right-hand side
that's a picture of James Cameron going
down to the bottom of the ocean at about
36,000 feet people in the history of our
planet have ever gone down to the bottom
of the ocean by contrast the very
good-looking chap on the left is our
space moon Walker and we've had 12 who
have walked on the moon she makes it fun
which I like because you wanna the
environment should be fun the ocean
spaces she seems unfocused here a little
bit but her style is to just be in and
out I don't really know what's going on
but I
I think it's good but just to put that
into perspective for you winning me over
a map the moon about 7:00 between 7
meters and 100 meters which is crazy
when you think of that nuts and also
what's odd is that since in the last 40
years since we've been to the moon we've
brought back about 850 pounds of moon
rocks again by contrast we take out
between a hundred and about a hundred
and thirty billion worth of fish tons of
fish a year now the variable as many of
you will know is because we don't really
know what what the value is on the
illegal fishing department because boats
as we know not all boats attract there
are about legal fraternity of people
have no idea how much your problem
illegal fishing is it's one of the
biggest problems in the country in the
world is illegal fishing people fishing
when they shouldn't without a permit and
stuff so much if it goes on and and and
it's I don't know this woman
but defected she has the guts and the
balls to kind of call out the illegal
fishermen to me he's huge let's let's
let it go for another few minutes
it's that attract for instance in the
high seas I'm just I would like you to
think about this for a second okay
I'd like to know how many of you would
like to fly on a plane if only 15% of
planes were talking to air traffic
control I don't want it I don't want to
owe again perhaps if driving specially
in a private plane from it seems a
little bit more comfortable here in
Iceland if only fifteen percent of the
drivers road had license plates no good
we all know I mean I'm a bit of a speed
demon so it allows them to fish for
endangered species but use a drone and
kill them chances that they'll be
captured after them that
less and so that's a problem because
it's putting alright well anyway the
Terramar project is what we're we've
just entered into a partnership with on
this show it's called the Terramar
project I don't know what that means I
think water and land or something and
and both are very necessary and this
this woman is [ __ ] bright and I don't
know who she is but I like I like the
cut of her jib and I just enjoy it and
so if you like me think illegal fishing
is the biggest problem in America and
the world you will get involved with
this Terramar project to really kind of
[ __ ] go and get those illegal boats
because we need to know who's fishing
that's the biggest issue that's the
biggest issue on the on the high seas
right now on the water
who is fishing where they shouldn't be
fishing so if there's any way that we
can find those people I think so many
other problems are are linked into this
illegal fishing it almost seems like
illegal fishing is the way that the
world is run you see there's all these
fishermen fishing illegally for fish
that they shouldn't have that they
should have thrown back into the water
and one fisherman knows that the other
fisherman is doing this with the illegal
fish she doesn't know and so there's
this weird
omerta like silence around the idea of
illegal fishing none of the illegal
fishermen tell on any of the other
illegal fishermen and nobody has a
[ __ ] license everybody just says
we're just going out for a fun you know
yacht day but it's not they're illegally
fishing taking fish they shouldn't have
and doing god only knows what to it on a
boat and they all have each other's back
and it's a code of silence and they
bribe each other in they blackmail each
other with these illegal fish and this
woman has the balls to call it out I
don't know how he pronounced your name
just something but god bless her and God
bless the Terramar project
Whitney Webb coming right up